[Music]
one of the main characters of ursula
kayla green's fourth earth-sea novel to
hanu is named theroux and she's named
that by tenor one of the other main
characters who takes her in
as a damaged abused child and this
happens in the very
first chapter
of the work we find that
lark comes and says gohan it's a very
bad thing it's a very bad thing can you
come
and
what is the bad thing a burned child
gohan is of course the use name of tenar
the character from tombs of atuan
and what do we what do we find here well
there is a story that that's told
by lark
they've been camped in the river meadows
all the month a man passed himself off
as a tinker but he's a thief and a woman
with him another man younger hanging
around with them most of the time not
working any of them filtering begging
and living off the woman boys from down
river were bringing them farm stuff to
get at her you know how it is now and
gangs on the road coming by farms if i
were you i'd lock my door so this one
the younger fellow comes into the
village and i was out in the front of
the house and he says the child's not
well
i'd barely seen a child with them a
little ferret of a thing slipped out of
sight so quick i wasn't sure it was
there at all so i said not well a fever
and the fellow says she hurt herself
lighting the fire and then before i had
got myself ready to go with him he'd
made off go on and when i went down
there by the river the other pair was
gone too cleared out all their traps and
trash gone too there was just their
campfire and smoldering and just buy it
partly in it
on the ground they haven't he hadn't
even put a blanket over her
she had been pushed into the fire while
it was burning
lark said she swallowed and brushed at
the sticking seeds on her hot face
i'd say maybe she fell but if she'd been
awake she'd have tried to save herself
they beat her and thought they'd killed
her i guess and wanted to hide what
they'd done to her so they
and then
gohan asks will she live and lark said
she might she might well live
and
lark says i don't know why i came to you
ivy's there there's nothing to be done
and
gohan says i could go to valmother beach
a sorcerer who could who could possibly
do something
and she says nothing he could do it's
beyond beyond help i got her warm
ivy the local witch has given her a
potion and a sleeping charm i carried
her home she must be six or seven but
she didn't weigh what a two-year-old
would she never really waked but she
makes a kind of gasping i don't know if
there's anything you can do
but i wanted you
and then tenar goha says i want to come
and all the other children have been
sent outside
the village witch had smeared an
ointment of witch hazel and heal
although lesser burns but did not touch
the right side of the face and head in
the right hand which had been charred to
the bone
she'd been she'd drawn the rune pier
above the bed and left it at that
and lark says you learned healing up on
the mountain didn't you
and
tenor says even ogian couldn't heal this
so
you know they
what do they do they they stay with the
child and see whether it's going to live
gohan
says
i served the the
powers of the earth and i left them i
will not let let them have you and the
chapter ends by saying
the child stared at her or at nothing
trying to breathe and trying again to
breathe and trying again to breathe it's
that close to
to death and what we find out later
from tenor when she's you know
summarizing what had happened
is that the abuse was
pretty horrific
um
she tells the the young king on the ship
that uh the man that she confronts was
one of the people who crippled the child
he and her parents they raped her and
beat her and burned her
these things happened my lord these
things happen to children and he keeps
following her to get at her
so
horrific abuse the sort of thing that
unfortunately in our world and also in
the world of earth see
does happen so often to children she's
starved malnourished you know we have
that remark about she you know should
have weighed a lot more
she's raped by
who knows the father
the same men that come to to visit her
mother
beaten beaten not just in the sense of
punished but they tried to kill her with
beating her and then pushed into
a fire and you can call these people
misguided or traumatized themselves but
leguin has no problem calling them evil
and and it's very clear that they
they are evil
tenor takes theroux and gives her a name
theroux
is a kargish name as her own child and
theroux
grows up with what appear to be some
significant
challenges and deficits
she doesn't speak for a long time it
takes her a while to
learn how to to trust even their
environment and the physical damage
is incredibly
extensive
so you know the healing that's going to
take place
and the scarring that's going to take
place
is very significant and it comes you
could say in three main
ways that are signaled in the novel one
has to do with the physicality her face
and hand are burned down to the bone her
eye is gone
her face is is completely damaged to the
point where when ged the uh former ark
mage
uh
comes you know
to is brought by the but by the dragon
and uh is is being nursed by
tenar at ogeon's
house
there's a sort of kinship that the child
recognizes because ged's face is scarred
not by fire but by
the the shadow that in the first wizard
of earth see
novel and she says um
he's like me
her face and her hand are
in in some respects unusable
and in other respects she's able to do
some things auntie moss the witch
teaches her how to use the the
essentially claw that she still has of
her right hand to do cat's cradle and
she adapts but there is very
serious damage done to her
her body and you know this gets
mentioned at a number of points you know
for example
um tenor
will will draw the child in with with
her right and
there's questions about what could be
what could be done
um
there's actually a great line here
this is about midway through the novel
and
she's tenar is sort of questioning
herself
she says
everything she tenor had done was wrong
she'd been given to the dark powers as a
child she'd been eaten by them she had
suffered to be eaten
did she think that by crossing the sea
by learning other languages by being a
man's wife a mother of children by
merely living her life she could ever be
anything but what she was their servant
their food theirs to use for their needs
and games
destroyed she had drawn the destroyed to
her part of her own ruin the body of her
own
evil and this is this is a really
significant line that we're going to
talk about a little bit later tenner
doesn't know whether she did the right
thing
but
she goes on and she says the child's
hair was fine warm sweet smelling she
lay curled up in the warmth of tenors
arms dreaming what wrong could she be
wronged
wrong beyond all repair but not wrong
there's a very important distinction
there that is is central to
healing of this sort of trauma wronged
but not wrong
not going to be recognized by everybody
else and that's when we can talk about
the social
stigma
against thera that takes place a little
bit earlier
in that section
she's talking uh and and uh
she'd hoped that ged could heal thiru
who lay his hand lay his hand on the
scar and it would be whole and well the
blind eye bright the clawed hands soft
the ruined life intact
knowing what her life must be
is said and then
we have this description the averted
faces the signs against evil the horror
and curiosity the sickly pity and the
prying threat for harm draws harm to it
and never a man's arms never anyone to
hold her never anyone but ten are
so
she's going to have to live with the
misunderstanding
of other people of what was done to her
the confusion
of this being wronged for
being wrong for being being evil for
being fearsome terrible things were done
to her which makes her
terrifying
to others and there's actually an
interesting discussion a little bit
later on actually several discussions
where bad things are happening to people
the powerful are imposing their will on
the power less and everybody else is
like well it's not really my business i
don't have to do anything about this
matter of fact maybe they had it coming
to them there's a line there where it's
assumed that the rich and the powerful
have some sort of virtue and that the
people that have bad things done to them
maybe on some level they deserved it so
that social stigma
is something that that is is a problem
just as important as a matter of fact
perhaps even more important because the
social stigma can be avoided by going
into a place where nobody else is
is the fear and the turning inward on
the part of thera she is
filled with fear at certain points by
the people who have done the evil to her
those four
her mother and father and the other two
in particular the one who's going to
show up the most is this man
handy
the man with the leather cap who is just
as wicked
as the rest of them and is trying to get
at her and she's afraid of them you know
understandably so because they did
horrific things to her that she is just
beginning to recover from
through tenar and the others uh you know
auntie moss
ged
um
you know the the others that are
involved with her the animals she's able
to
theroux is able to
unclench to unfold to begin to
engage with other people but the only
people that she doesn't really
show fear of at first our tenor and lark
and then later on
uh others who are interacting with her
but she doesn't have a general
trust of of human beings right
so um
i'm going to
read you some of the the passages
that have to do with that in just a
moment
um
there is this question
was it good for tenor to take her in or
would it been better for thera to die
tenner
waivers back and forth about this and
there's actually a discussion
between
she and ged
ged tells her at one point that
um
you know
she
in some respect
might not have done the right thing but
she
had to do it that there wasn't any
other
path forward for her
that
it's like ged and dealing with his own
challenge imposed by the
the shadow
and tenor
is unsure whether she did the right
thing as time goes on
that that worry goes away as she can see
thero
developing and there's i suppose you can
say there's actually a point where
this is driven home to her how much
how much value thero has when we're
dealing with handy and the rest of the
evil band that are trying to
get at her there's uh the first time is
at the
ocean's house
and she sees um
she sees
this guy
handy
going off to ray albee
and then she goes up
to the house and she can't find
the child
and
she's worried you know where where is
thero there we go
she went to ogen's house and a short way
passed it up the forest path calling as
she came back through the meadow the
kestrel was hunting in the same spot
where gathered watched it hunt
and she goes on and she says she must
search
around the house the spring house the
milking shed more carefully this was her
fault she'd caused it to happen by
thinking of making pharaoh into a weaver
shutting her away in the dark to work to
be respectable she knew a wrong that
cannot be repaired must be transcended
when she knew the child had been given
her and she failed in her charge failed
in her trust lost her lost the one great
gift
she went into the house having searched
every corner of the other buildings
looked into the alcove and around the
other bed she poured herself water for
her mouth was dry as sand
behind the door the three sticks of wood
ogee and staff and the walking sticks
moved in the shadows and one of them
said here
the child was crouched in that dark
corner drawn into her own body so that
she seemed no bigger than a little dog
head bent down to the shoulder arms and
legs pulled tight in the one eye shut
little bird little sparrow a little
flame what is wrong what happened what
have they done to you now then tenor
says how could you frighten me so how
could you hide from me oh i was so angry
she wept and her tears fell on the
child's face oh therotherothera don't
hide away from me
a shudder went through the knotted limbs
and slowly they loosened theroux moved
and all at once clung to tenar pushing
her face into the hollow between tenor's
breast and shoulder clinging tighter
until she was clutching desperately she
did not weep she never wept her tears
had been burned out of her maybe she had
none but she made a long moaning sobbing
sound
tell me
the woman murmured and the child
answered in her faint horse whisper he
came here
tenor's first thought was of ged
and then she realized who came here
a man
a man in a leather cat theroux nodded
once we saw him on the road
so
she asked do you know him pharaoh
yes
from when you lived in the camp by the
river one nod
he came here she said and all the fears
she tell she felt turned as she spoke
into anger a rage that burned in her the
length of her body like a rod of fire
and then tenor makes a promise to her he
will never touch you pharaoh understand
me and believe me he will never touch
you again
he'll never see you again unless i'm
with you and then he must deal with me
do you understand my dear my precious my
beautiful
you need not fear him
you must not fear him he wants you to
fear him he feeds on your fear we will
starve him thera will starve him till he
eats himself till he chokes gnawing on
the bones of his own hands
ah don't listen to me now i'm only angry
angry
and so
there's a little bit more the idea of
the man's coming to the house being in
the house coming to look at his
handiwork maybe thinking of improving
upon it that idea when it recurred to
tenure came less as a thought than as a
queasy fit a need to vomit but the
nausea burned itself out against the
anger so this is a very important
exchange here
there's a lot going on
this notion that the man is going to
come and finish what he started or
improve upon his work the abuser
wants to continue abusing
in this case the vulnerable child who
he's already imposed so much upon
he wants her fear
and tenor is both angry
as a result and
nauseated and wants to drive that fear
away as well and and this is really the
proper response to that sort of
evil
the next time is in the port of got
and this time tenor is actually under a
spell from the evil sorcerer of rey alby
aspen and taking tenor down to
the harbor and handy is pursuing them as
a matter of fact handy even tries to
take
uh thero from her and it's only the
people on on the boat
who end up um
saving them
handy says you know you don't have to
run away i don't mean you any harm i
don't want to hurt you you don't
understand i was the one who got help
for her wasn't i i was really sorry what
happened i want to help you with her he
put out his hand as if drawn
irresistibly to touch the arrow tenner
could not move she'd promised theroux he
would never touch her again
she saw the hand touch the child's bare
flinching arm what do you want with her
said another voice another sailor had
taken the place of the bald one a young
man tenor thought he was her son handy
was quick to speak as the abusers always
are they've always got a line ready
right she's got she took my kid my niece
it's mine she witched it she ran off
with it see
and tenner
is having a hard time even speaking she
says let me come aboard please the young
man held out his hand she took it he
brought her across the gangway and onto
the deck of the ship wait here he said
to handy and to her come with me
she sank into a heap on the deck of the
ship from have nor dropping the heavy
sack but clinging to the child don't let
him take her oh don't let him have her
not again not again not again and this
is where the story comes out turns out
the young man is actually the king and
the king is going to set things straight
either himself or through his
intermediaries later in the book
she tells him what they they did to to
um
to pharaoh
and
the king says i'm sorry i let the man go
but he can be found again you know
and they uh talk about about get and
then
while they're on the boat
theroux is terrified and it takes a lot
to get her to
relax she won't even talk to people
one of the sailors carves a beautiful
bone
or ivory dolphin for her tenner says it
can live in your grass bag with the
others the bone people
at that thero came to life enough to
fetch out her grass bag and put the
dolphin in it but tenor had to go thank
the humble giver thera would not look at
him
or speak
and here's where there's some interior
monologue on the part of tennar about
what's what's been done
it's so easy she thought with rage it's
so easy for handy to take the sunlight
from her take the ship and the king and
her childhood from her and it's so hard
to give them back
a year i've spent trying to give them
back to her and with one touch
he takes them and throws them away
and what good does it do to him what's
his prize
is his power is power that
an emptiness
and so
this is a really key key line
what is it that these people the abusers
are actually going to get what are they
after
it's worthless to them what they end up
getting and it does so much damage to
the traumatized child
then there's a third time where
uh the three men come to
gohan or tenar's farm and try to break
in to take the child fortunately ged has
come along with them although not
accompanying them and stabs one of them
with a pitchfork and the others scatter
eventually they'll all be
hung
by by the king's justices
and
you know this is one more time in which
the abusers are trying to get at
uh
there or
yeah thero and to
harm her to damage her again
there's so much going on here what it
what is it that they want they want to
possess they want to destroy they want
to as
tener remarked earlier to improve upon
their handiwork and it's all for
nothing
it won't give them
any satisfaction
healing as we find out in this this
story is not something that in so many
novels and television shows and films
is this you know one thing happens and
then everything falls into place good
will hunting being told it's not your
fault right
real healing isn't like that real
healing is a cumulative process one step
forward
one step back it can be undone
by people coming in from the outside to
re-traumatize the child and it requires
not only patience
but effort and working through
not knowing whether you're actually
doing the right thing
there's this great line here that i'll
end with
in this where um
tenari is is uh making a dress a red
dress for theroux a red dress with a
white apron for fancy wearing an orangey
brown one for every day
now then you look beautiful satenar in
her seamstresses pride when they first
tried it on theroux turned her face away
you are beautiful tenor said in a
different tone listen to me thero come
here
you have scars ugly scars because an
ugly evil thing was done to you
people see the scars but they see you
too and you aren't the scars you aren't
ugly you aren't evil you are thiru and
beautiful you are thero who can work and
walk and run and dance beautifully in a
red dress
the child listened the soft unhurt side
of her face as expressionless as the
rigid scar mask side
she looked down at tenor's hands and
presently touched them with her small
fingers
it's a beautiful dress she said in her
faint hoarse voice
when tenor was alone folding up the
scraps of red material
tears came stinging into her eyes she
felt rebuked she had done right to make
the dress and she'd spoken the truth to
the child
but it was not enough
the right and the truth there was a gap
a void a gulf on beyond the right and
the truth
love
her love for thero and theros for her
made a bridge across that gap a bridge
of spider web but love did not fill it
or close it nothing did that
and the child knew it better than she
what a great way of summarizing what can
be done
to
help healing in those who are
traumatized
but also a recognition that these values
truth rightness love
don't actually efface don't
erase what has happened
there is that earlier line about instead
of simply filling things in transcending
them
that is where
it happens most explicitly in this story
you